there is some anti-marriage propaganda
going around on Tick Tock puts an
engagement ring on on the wrong hand
actually
and
every time she she puts it on she's she
sees a vision of herself cooking
cleaning being barefoot and pregnant
holding a baby you're working so hard
and she puts it down she says no thank
you I'm out I'm out don't need that
don't want marriage it's half true it's
half true in that when you get married
you will be cooking and cleaning and if
you're a good wife you'll be cooking and
cleaning and having babies and taking
care of the babies and keeping a home
and you'll be doing you will be doing
all those things and there is joy that
comes from that